[MUSIC PLAYING]
Hi.
My name is Daniel Pham,
and welcome to "This Week
in Android Development" for
Monday, November 18, 2013.
Both Reto Meier and not Reto
Meier are indisposed this week,
so I'll be taking the
reins and providing
your weekly dose
of updates today.
Last week, Neto Marin
released another "DevByte"
in Portuguese.
Our faithful teammates presented
various talks at Devoxx
in Belgium, and Reto graced
AnDevCon in San Francisco
with the keynote
speech delivered
in his charming, natural
New Zealander accent.
This week, "Game On!"
is back from hiatus.
Todd returns from
his short stint
working on top secret
projects to celebrate
the half birthday of Play Games.
In app update news, Pandora's
got a fresh tablet UI
with Chromecast integration,
while Ski Safari
has updated to
include Play Games
integration, Leaderboards,
and Cloud Sync.
That's all for "This Week
in Android Development."
Be sure to check out
our shows this week.
I'm Daniel Pham, and that kind
of luxe just ain't for us.
We crave a different
kind of buzz.